this week convict zone is in London
where I caught up with one of Europe's
best-known and shortest serving
politicians he's Yanis varoufakis there
was Greece's Finance Minister during the
recent turbulent debt negotiations he
ended up being sidelined by his own
government seen by many as an obstacle
to getting an agreement did he
ultimately do more harm than good
Yanis varoufakis welcome to conflict
zone thank you
it's a few weeks now since Greece signed
the third bailout in five years which
you called capitulation said you've been
set up
variously described it as blackmail but
the European public isn't buying that is
it still blames you and your government
for the debt crisis why are you not
getting that message across it's not the
sensation I have when I walk on the
streets of Paris Berlin Rome indeed I
get exactly the opposite of you it's my
view that it's us Mary Paul cross nine
European countries August the
twenty-eighth shows that some 88% say
the Greek government is a great deal or
a fair amount to blame for the crisis
there's a high figure something pretty
much so and if I were asked in August I
would probably have to say the same
thing that we are culpable in the sense
that we did not maintain a firm position
that we should have maintained so you
know how polls are you broke your
promise
we did broken break a promise because
there was only one promise but we're not
going to further extend and pretend
extend the crisis to the future by
accepting another loan which we will add
on existing unsustainable debt and
pretended to solve the crisis not to
cross your red lines which you wrote
about in February in the New York but I
thought was the main red line we
wouldn't this we would desist from doing
anything that was against Greece's
interest that's what you wrote then you
signed an agreement that I didn't say is
right against him I didn't I resigned on
the night when it was up to me but you
were speaking on behalf of the
government about that point I was and
when the collective responsibility
indeed and and when the government
clearly was of a mind to violate the
commitment which I wrote about and I
spoke about back in January February
March
I designed what else can a politician do
I want to come onto that a bit later but
let's let's go back to that first
Eurogroup meeting you said to them we
hear your concerns about us and we need
to put them to rest indeed but you never
did did you I think we did if you look
for instance at the proposals that I
table tabled at the Eurogroup regarding
reforms regarding the sustainability of
US fiscal position regarding
restructuring without any haircuts and
in a manner that maximized the value
that our creditors would get back from
us these were very sensible very
moderate proposals that indeed we're not
even left-wing they were just common
sense once I was told that they
resembled something that the bankruptcy
lawyer from Wall Street with a small
reformist agenda would put forward you
said there were sensible one troika
official said the ease with which you
requested other European taxpayers to
settle your debts had an undemocratic
air about it yes but that is subterfuge
on their behalf because what they're
doing now is they're guaranteeing they
are making the absolute certain well I
mean you and I know that human nature
has a certain reluctance to admit
failure the troika has been imposing a
reform agenda in inverted commas a
reform agenda for five years upon grace
that has made Greece under for mobile
and has deepened the dead deflationary
cycle took issue with you on that it
said your country had achieved much
since receiving the bailout loans
reducing the budget deficit from 15% of
national income in 2009 to 3% in 2014
actually is better than that and I've
been advocating now saying we are the
champions rather than being the cause of
all your woes you did quite well not in
the slightest isn't he that the the
consolidation is a means to an end it's
not the end in itself the cut
expenditure in order to achieve an aim
which is to
to render your debt sustainable let me
just bring this down to to the essence
you did quite well under the previous
bailouts the third quarter of 2004 the
financially put growth
topped the eurozone lead by a table you
were doing quite well you said it's the
cause of all your ills well the other
bailouts you have and they're taking
issue with you on that
okay allow me to answer these two very
important points firstly it is true that
the government's from 2010 11 on to 2004
14 did turn Greece into the champion of
austerity we cut massively we turned and
this was a magnificent turnaround we
turned a huge budget deficit into the
large structural surplus in Europe that
is a success that was this is you wanted
to reverse not the slightest not the
slightest allow me to complete my
sentence this was the instrument that we
used to achieve a target which is the
target was want the target was not to
have a surplus in the budget the target
was to start growing the economy again
and to make the debt sustainable the
result I was forcing spending cuts and
tax increases tracking the economic
reforms let me finish
Greek GDP fell precipitously and our
debt skyrocketed the whole point of this
30 was to make the debt sustainable our
debt when we started in 2010 with 120
percent of GDP now it's almost 200
percent that's a spectacular failure of
this program you face so there's you if
they studied events the lighter payment
burden than Italy Spain and Portugal
Klaus regaling who's the head of the
European financial stability verse
facility he said Greece has already
received by far the most generous
lending conditions ever granted to
bailout countries I wasn't good enough
flight didn't now care for the truth
because the truth is because he lied did
he well let's say he was economical with
it with the truth
that's that's a powerful statement I was
the senior figure he wasn't the only one
things invite me on your program to give
you powerless statements did you so
allow me to point in the truth yes well
the truth is this the truth is that in
2010 the Greek state was bankrupt and
Europe in its infinite wisdom decided to
hide that bankruptcy to pretend that it
was not the case of bankruptcy but it
was a case of lack of liquidity and he
tried to pretend that we were not
bankrupt by granting as the largest loan
in economic history 110 billion first
and then another hundred 20 on condition
of austerity that shrank our income from
which we had to repay the old loans and
any loans never end well but
nevertheless reduced your budget deficit
from 15 years the instrument you judge a
program on the basis of its outcome not
on the basis of the instrument the
outcome was a catastrophe there is why
they had to give us the as Klaus
Reckling said debt relief was because
our debt was completely unsustainable as
a result of the failure of the program
so you you you made these arguments you
made these arguments countless times and
they did you completely and utterly
accept it by anyone who has any sense of
economic logic in the EU you didn't seem
to you didn't seem to worry about that
yes sir excuse me my my statement in the
Eurogroup always when I addressed my
Slava Slovak colleague my Slovenian
colleague was that what we are tabling
here in front of you is a recommendation
and proposal which if you accept your
receipts from us our repayments to you
is there to get nothing back because
they are imposing a program upon Greece
which will ensure that will not get
their money back
former Latvian prime minister validus
Dombrowski's said no one says Greece has
to leave the EU but people feel
humiliated and in many countries people
don't care about Greece anymore it's
hard for me if I'm Prime Minister to
explain why we poor should help the rich
Greeks the Greeks can do their reforms
if they want to but not with our money
that was the response
well you said that you said they were
buying your arguments clearly they
weren't well I said that the IMF I said
did he over the seller said anybody who
has any sense of economic logic boater
arguments and that that's pretty
insulting that that's pretty insulting
it's a former prime minister this
fracture it's fractured knew the truth
here
well not only didn't the International
Monetary Fund boots on debt
sustainability they agree with me
formally Iranian officials said this
general with me every expert story you
may say this how couldn't possibly
comment but what I can comment I said
you melt it an American female it was
worth what is the Greek debt to GDP
ratio today it's to almost edging
towards two hundred percent clearly
going from one a hundred and twenty
percent when we had the debt crisis to
two hundred percent is not a success
story the point I've been making in the
Eurogroup is if you insist on striking
the cow that is to produce the milk
you're going to kill it and not get the
milk okay you know order to get more
milk so that you get the page agree with
us that we need to have a sensible a
sensible policy towards primary services
and debt so that you can get more money
i I understand the arguments but they
apparently they are the only sensible
arguments around the table well okay so
you accuse a lot of people of having
nonsense of are you you you said you
were set up if the fix was in if you
were set up
why did they waste so much time on all
these discussions with you day after day
night after night week after week month
after month well crises to manage they
had migrants they had Russia and Ukraine
there plenty of things on the edge they
had some energy on the migrant issue
they spent none of it and this is a
great disgrace for the European Union
and a great honor for the German
government that in the last few days
they've shown some leadership on this
matter
unfortunately we have a monetary union
which is unsustainable Greek crisis
Greece was the canary in the mine
and Europe was in denial of the
architectural fault lines within the
euro zone Greece's is just a collateral
damage to them okay it was just a pawn
in on it like a chessboard
the great battle is between Paris and
Berlin at the moment you keep making
them put did you did you ever lost the
first time I made this point in your
program a similar point did you ever lie
during the negotiations no did you ever
mislead no but I was lied to and I was
misled by my interlocutors when you find
a very large number of occasions when
you flew to the IMF in Washington on
Easter Sunday yes to see Christine
Lagarde yes I get more flexible payment
terms yes you said very carefully in the
New York Times spoke to people who were
close to you you said that Greece would
intend intended to meet its payment
obligations you said to people close to
you that you had deliberately used the
word intend instead of will despite the
fact that people would take that as a
commitment not slightest henshin ly
misleading not in the slightest I spent
two and a half hours with Christine
Lagarde in her office with a very
pleasant conversation a very frank
exchange and in that I explained the
difference our intention was indeed to
meet our obligations to the IMF and to
all let me finish my stew my sentence
our intention was to do that this is
what we wanted to do it but there's a
fundamental profound difference between
desire and capacity we will our finances
were being depleted wouldn't meet those
obligations
I knew there was going to be a point in
time when we would no longer be able to
afford it so why just I come out with
the phrase intend to because its
obligations because it was completely
utterly realistic to say that we
intended to and we were asking for their
sakes it's a false impression not
incited this is what I said to Christine
Lagarde and Christine Lagarde knew
exactly what I meant and she agreed with
me because you know what
the moment I became finance minister
just even
before I'd become fine I'm Finance
Minister there was a banker and a
slow-burning banker and happening in
Greece and the stock exchange was
collapsing the first thing I did was to
come to London here where we are now and
I spoke to more than 200 investors and
the next morning the stock exchange of
Greece and Bank shares went up by 10
between 10 and 20 percent the following
day the day after that the central bank
of Europe instead of supporting me in my
efforts pull the rug from under am I
asking you will or intend to well don't
you understand so hard to understand the
difference between saying I want to pay
you back but I'm not sure that I will
manage to took it is it I'm sorry but I
think I'm perfectly clear in the use of
of English I won't I are you know we are
a very proud people we want to meet all
our obligations to all our creditors
that doesn't mean we can afford it and
what we are asking of our partners and
the International Monetary Fund and the
ECB and the Commission was for that and
almost unity to be able to produce the
wealth that is necessary for us to meet
enormous obligations of mismanagement by
the eurozone and by previous quicker
yeah this very focus as a proud man why
did you say you would where the
creditors loathing with pride because
the creditors in the case of the euro
zone in Greece have done something that
will go down in history as despicable
but why make it personal why make it
personal between you and them because
they made it personal because they
leaked awful stories which were untrue
about what was said to me in Riga
because various comments were made even
in my presence in the Euro group which
were but forum let's say and I never
retaliated on those occasions never you
enjoyed sticking in em you told the
Italians their debt was unsustainable
that was not true this is another case
optionally exceptional distortion of the
part of the press I had made that
statement in December 2010 in an
interview
I was completely correct as history
proved to say that the Greek crisis
would bring Italy down unless and until
the ECB act exactly and then when I
became Finance Minister listen to this
team because you can't just throw this
into the mix and expect me to let you
get away with it and then what the press
did in Italy was to retrieve something I
said in 2010 and pretend I said it in
2015 okay you never lectured or hectored
a lot of people said you did well a lot
of people said you were the need to
control my accusers team tell you what I
said to them what there was a question
from both enjoyably fine correct if I
remember correctly and he said to me you
don't like the idea of a fall and a half
percent primary surplus for Greece what
would you want the primary surplus to be
and I said to give you a firm answer as
to what it should be
I should we should also discuss the
degree of debt restructuring and also
the investment plan and credit plan we
have for the non-performing loans of the
banks because this is like a system of
equations in now number of unknowns you
can't fix one without fixing the other
and then you know what I was accused of
of lecturing them on macroeconomics okay
it is actually testimony to the lack of
sophistication of the Eurogroup that a
finance minister is accused of talking
economics in the Eurogroup okay I think
that sophisticated
they've lost their hold on economics
any serious discussion about on
economics or macroeconomics in the
Eurogroup that is something that the
citizens of Europe should know about and
this is something that they should be
very worried about the reports they were
getting from the people who spoke up
time and time again respected people
according to you everybody's been lying
but somebody here in a bad way took
place exchange somebody here in France
not credible Yanis varoufakis
well everybody has lied about this
except you well that's strange you are
interviewing me
I can only tell you what I experienced I
experienced a hero group in which the
degree of sophistication of the economic
narrative was next to zero and when I
tried because I was representing a
country that was suffering from a
humanitarian crisis as a result as a
result of macroeconomic mismanagement
I tried to bring to the conversation
sophisticated Makana work that you did
either one troika representative said
the stuff they sent us was
extraordinarily naive in March she was
said to have submitted a proposal aimed
on anything where they were giving us
just finish the question let you finish
in March she was said to have submitted
a proposal aimed at boosting sales tax
compliance which involved hiring amateur
spies sometimes tourists who'd be
trained to wear hidden cameras
the troika representatives it was
stunning to see something like this from
an EU finance minister well let me they
were starlit okay this is this is
something that that leaves me completely
unabashed because I can say this to you
in the summer of 2014
according to my own ministry sources the
tourist arrivals in on the island of
Mykonos and the ad of Santorini doubled
doubled doubled tourism and our VT tax
take went down by 30 percent immediately
you realize there is a scandalous
failure of the tax collection system I
bring up the tax office and I try to
find out why that failure took place and
they told me that they have no tax
collectors on these islands and the
moment it tax collector board the ship
imperious
to go to these islands suddenly alarm
bells ring all over the place and their
work is completely annulled okay so my
proposal my proposal that we hire as on
the basis of short term contracts I
didn't mention to I mentioned to this as
well but anybody but you reject help the
surveillance systems of restaurants and
pubs and bars
where there was a rampant tax evasion
I'm very proud of that suggestion have
it happens in America all the time why
shouldn't it have if the IRS does it why
can't we do it if if you were so hated
as you said you were I wasn't hated well
you said you wore their loathing with
pride so like so you knew that people
had strong feelings about you
how didn't you come to the point where
it was impossible to do your job on
behalf of Greece if you were the
impediment if it was personal against
you you say they made it personal
shouldn't you have stepped down then Tim
when you let me out let me out his verse
the tables here by asking you a question
what happened when I left was there a
viable agreement no there was an
agreement but the Prime Minister my
prime minister also my successor my good
friend euclid tsakalotos who signed that
agreement came to Parliament and said
this is a non viable agreement if my
progresses it's going to take Greece
forward the only thing I impede it was a
non-viable agreement okay what I was
doing in the Europe was I was saying to
them I shall not sign another extend and
pretend agreement this time around I'm
not going to do what my predecessors did
which was to not accept another huge wad
of money when I cannot guarantee to my
creditors to the people of Slovakia also
veneer of this Venice I can't repay them
the money but you owed me because I was
not going to take another predatory
letter which says you knew that we would
not be able to but your government did
and that is a disgrace and this is why I
wasn't part of it and I resigned and why
following the referendum which gave you
the no vote that you wanted
why did you squander that why why I
didn't squander that you said it was
squandered it was squandered by the
government passive tense and active
tense well let me just answer the
question on the night of the of the
referendum but what would you have done
differently I'll tell you but first let
me ask you to answer the first question
the first question is what happened on
the night of the referendum I found out
that our government didn't Prime
Minister were dejected by the no vote
which we had called the Greeks to give
us
and turned it into a no and therefore I
resigned what would I have done
differently we would not have reached
that point if my recommendations had
been hurt because from April onwards I
was arguing that it is essential that
Greece presents its own MOU but you said
a no vote would strengthen your
bargaining positions provided we wanted
to bargain but it didn't because we
didn't want to bargain after that my
Prime Minister decided to surrender on
the night of their fur and so in a sense
I feel very complicit in having called
Greeks to vote no and then turn that
into a yes without using the power and
the energy that the courageous Greek
voters gave us with this astonishing 62
percent who voted for the no and then we
just threw it in the biddin your
government Yanis varoufakis
broke several key promises when you look
back on your time as a minister did you
do more harm than good
absolutely not what we did was
negotiating cost Greece quite a bit of
money didn't it we did one EU official
an extra 30 billion well this is all
derived opposed this is just the same
terrible arithmetic that also
acknowledged that the bill was going up
at the time that you were yes but whose
fault it was good whose befall was that
we were being asked your continuing to
negotiate and not come up with what was
okay maybe our proposals were not
written by God and His angels maybe they
could have been better
we had no proposal from the troika the
first proposal that came to us from the
troika came to us on the 25th of June we
were we kept putting proposals to them
why can't we agree to pass the necessary
legislation with your help to implement
it while having a review of the whole
package mmm okay act immediately now and
I was told that if I dare make the
suggestion again of joint action by our
European friends and the troika and the
Greek in the new Greek government on on
on specific issues before the
comprehensive review is completed this
would be considered tassels belli by the
troika they didn't care about it they
only care about humiliating a government
that had
the the audacity to say to them that
their program over there our previous
five years was a spectacular failure
which it was a less fair focus one
comment what do you think you learned
from all this what do you take away one
sentence
for a small fragile relatively corrupt
economy like Greece to rise up and
demand the opportunity to reform when
Paris and Berlin have not sought it out
amongst themselves how they want to
restructure the eurozone is a very hard
job thanks very much for being on
complex
thank you thank you
you